minna-san konnichiwa positive are  confutatis Java challenge infinity  No a taraji episode oh yeah stay tight  oh my muscle  concave are you're not challenging  guardians are Ithaca  you take my show now it's time to play  with the silver play button  almost  oh we've got that beautiful  [Music]  and guys remember to subscribe so we can  reach 1 million and turn this one gold  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  this is such a dangerous job okay so  this is table tennis tennis tennis  tennis table  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  nice  [Music]  nice  [Music]  okay so with added length so we can hit  hard I know what you're trying  [Music]  okay  [Music]  oh that's nice thanks watching guys to  remember to subscribe here and what the  previous episode from there